그 업체랑 아니면 그 사람이랑은
거래를 하시면 안
[음악]
됩니다네 안녕하세요 빌사남 있니다
제가 오늘은 공인 중개사인 중개
보조원 있지 확인하는 방법에 대해서
알려 드리도록 하겠습니다 우선
인터넷에 월드라고 검색하시면 여기
부동산 중개업을 조회할 수 있는
서비스가 있어요 그래서 여기에 해당
구와 업체 명을 쓰면은 이렇게 어
조회가 가능합니다 그래서 여기 밑에
내려보면
공인중개사인 중개보조원 있지 여기
등록을 하게 돼 있어요 그래서
여러분들이 나에게 집을 소개했 그나
나에게 빌딩을 소개했던 사람이
중개사인 중개 보조인지 확인할 필요가
있습니다 근데 만약에 그 사람이 여기
검색했는데 안 나오거나 아니면
업체명이 안 나오면 그 업체랑 아니면
그 사람이랑은 거래를 하시면 안
됩니다 무조건 중개업을 하면 여기에
등록을 해야 되기 때문에 그냥
불법으로 하시는 분들도 있거든요네
아니면은 내가 뭐 자격증 없는 거를
들키기 싫기 때문에 등록을 안 한
사람들이 있습니다 그래서 그
사람들이랑 거래하면 매우 위험하기
때문에 반드시 거래하기 전에 이거를
검색해 보셨으면 좋겠습니다 그리고
중개 보조원이 중개사의 차이는 뭐냐면
일단 자격증이 없는게 차이고 중개
보조는 누구나 다 4시간만 교육을
받으면은 신청을 할 수 있습니다
그래서 진입 장벽이 높지 않고 사고를
치고 퇴사하는 경우가 굉장히 많아요
진짜 우리나라 안타까운 현실이긴
하지만 중계 법인 업체 같은 경우에는
예를 들어서 10명이다 하면 일곱명
여덟명 아니면 그 이상 보조원이
경우가 되게 많습니다 문제가 되는
경우가 되게 많아요 근데 이제 업체
입장에서는 엄청 많은
보조원들이 많거든요 근데 그게 사실
해선은 안 되는 겁니다 아직까지
우리나라에 그렇게 하는 업체들이 좀
많이 있고요 그리고 사실 중계
보조원은 단순 사무보조 그다음에 현장
안내까지 할 수 있어요 그래서 뭐
예를 들어서 중계를 한다든지 이런
행위를 해서는 안 됩니다 근데
우리나라는 아직까지 그렇게 중계
보조원이 중계까지 하는 경우가 되게
많이 있거든요 실제 업무에선 그런게
사라져야 됩니다 그런 일들도 발생되서
안 되고 그런 거와 비슷한 거예요
제가 만약 병원에 가는데이 사람이 뭐
영업은 되게 잘해요 친절하게 영업은
잘하는데 실제로 내가 수술 하려고
했는데이 사람이 의사 면허가 없는
겁니다 그 사람한테 과연 맡길까요
여러분 되게 큰 일입니다 중개사
자격증이 있는지 확인하는 건 가장
기본이고 중개사가 진짜 내 업무를
담당해 줘야지이 사람이 책임감을 갖고
일을 합니다 그래서 여러분들 반드시
부동산 거래하실 때 월드의 어
중계사인 중개 보조원 있지 확인하시고
거래를 해야지 내 안전한 소중한
자산을 지킬 수 있다라고 저는 생각을
합니다 그래서 오늘 영상은 여기까지
하고요 다음 시간에 뵙도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다
[음악]
e